depuis une semaine une équipe de cinéma
tourna court métrage aborde une draisine
sur le rail de l'aérotrain entre artenay
cercottes le réalisateur et acteur
originaire d'orléans réalise son premier
film sous forme d'un road movie d'une
quarantaine de minutes et d'une du film
est née à l'époque quand j'étais au
fresnoy le viaduc de l'aérotrain j'ai
toujours vu toujours connu et j'ai eu
vraiment l'image de deux hommes en train
de pomper sur le viaduc et andrew et l
artiste invité qui me suivaient sur mon
projet donc le deuxième pont peur qui
pompe avec moi et je
un jour je lui ai dit je vais raconter
cette image et il m'a dit ouais c'est
une super image il faut vraiment la
faire en film de développer et je lui
dit andrew si je trouve les financements
est ce que tu es prêt à pompe et avec
moi et puis mme faye est ou de suisse
son complice artiste anglais a été
séduit par l'univers loufoque et absurde
du projet dans un de ses derniers films
il a longé les côtes anglaises avant de
rejoindre londres en pédalo l'idée dans
ma tête est toujours vraiment basté
kitten vraiment de charlie chaplin
vraiment comme j'ai déjà dit à
absolutiste et ça me stresse beaucoup
beaucoup réalisent bien le film a du
temps en temps mais en d'habitude non il
est complètement nul toujours nous du
temps en temps nickel merdique mais on
d'habitude nul ça vous plaît ça me plaît
beaucoup
j'adore produit par l' agence
tourangelle l'image d'après le film pulp
devrait sortir au printemps 2016 est de
présenter lors de festivals